من المهجر في في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه
كانت هنالك احيانا اتصالات لكن ليست
بالهاتف يعني له صديق كان دائما يزوره من
اصدقائه القدام
اعرفه كان احيانا يبلغني سلامه والعكس
بالعكس انا املغ سلامي والتحياتي غاضب منك
لانه
مرات في في التلفزات التونسيه
اا اعرف ان همم
الرئيس رحمه الله
حسن من تلك الكلمه يخش
لابد من ذلك لان الكلمه ليست سهله ولكن
تصور ان ان زعلته يعني لا ادري لانه قال
لي حتى لكن مش نحكي لك الحكايه بوضوح
الرئيس اعرفه على مدى سنوات وهو رجل
تكوينه عسكري وهو جنرال في الجيش
وكان وزير الاول وليس جمهوريه منتخب مهما
قيل في الانتخابات
وبالتالي
وكل ما نعرفه انه هرب كما قيل يعني ليس
لدينا اي معلومات عن كيف خرج هل كان ذلك
عنوه هل بالتخويف هل وقعت خيانه هل هنالك
شيء من هذا القلب
عليه عرفه جيدا في في قلب الازمه
ويغادر او فيما يقوله بعض الناس يعني يخلق
المكان
استدعتني احدى القنوات التونسيه في حوار
بعد سنه منها القديم ولا شرحته
عن طريق صديقي هذا شكرا هو همم انه يتفهم
هذا
وانه
لم يغادر من تلقائي نفسه هذا هذا ما قيل
قال لك نقل لك ذلك